では始めます カンハンダンマン・ヴィッパハーヤ・スカン・バーウェータパンディトー・オーカー・アノーカン・アガンマ・ヴィヴェーケーヤット・ドゥーラマン
タトラービラティ・ミッチ・ミッチェイェー・ヒトワカーミ・アキンキノ
パリヨーダペイェ・アッターナン・チッタ・クレーセーヒ・パンディトー
イェサン・サンボーディア・ンゲソー・サッマ・チッタ・スー・バーウィタン
アーダナ・パティ・ニッサンゲ・アヌパダーヤ・エーラタ
キーナー・サバージュ・ティーマントー・テー・ローケー・パリ・ニブブタ
では意味を考えてみましょう
カンハンダンマンという言葉には
このカンナというのは黒いという意味ですね
ダンマは物事で 現象で
いわゆる悪い物事ということですね
ヴィッパハーヤ そういうのはやめて
スッカン・バーウェータ
スッカンというのは白いということで
良いという意味なんです
バーウェータ 育てられるべきであると
パンディトー 知恵ある人がね
理性があるならば 悪い行為をやめて
善行為をどんどん進んでいくんでしょうと
次の行は結構難しいんですけど
オーカアノーカン・アガンマ・ヴィヴェーケーヤット・ドゥーラマン
これは意味は理解できないとは思いますけど
オーカっていうのは家
家という意味ですが 皆様よく知っている有識
仏教ではね 阿羅耶識ということがありますね
このアーレアという言葉ですね
で アーレアっていうのは家っていう意味なんです
そこを捨ててアノーカン
アーナレア これを捨てて
家を捨てて乗り越えなさいということですね
境地二つですね 家がある境地と家がない境地というね
あれに依存してね 頼っている境地と
アーレアを乗り越えたっていう
乗り越えた境地に達してくださいと
ヴィヴェーケーヤット・ドゥーラマン
それからヴィヴェーカっていう離れることですね
休むことですね 離れることはにも達してくださいと
それはドゥーラマン なかなか一般の人々には
それは喜ばないことであると
それで一行だけしか説明はできませんけど
カンナンダンマンっていうのは
まあ黒い汚れた生き方ということになるんです
汚れた生き方というのは
このごく普通の生き方のことなんですね
生き方と言ったってこの三つでしょ
考えることと喋ることと体の行為ですね
そう すごい難しく考えないで
コンパクトに頭に入れた方がいいとは思いますね
生き方 生き方といったらすごいすごい大きく見えますけど
まあ生きているということは
考えることと喋ることと体でいろいろ行為をやることなんですね
そこは我々はどんな生き物もやっているんですね
別に誰も生き方について何か学んだり訓練したりすることはないんです
生まれつきそれなりに物事を考えたり
喋ったり 行動したりする
誰一人もこのように思考するべきだというふうに
この思考 正しい思考を学ぶ訓練はしていないし
言葉を喋る訓練はしていないし
体の行為についても それなりの正しい行為という訓練はしていないんですね
ごく普通に生きているだけなんです
それが汚れた生き方というんですね
自分を育ててないならば
育ててない自分を正しいとはちょっと言いにくいんですよ
ですから 人の本来の生き方
生命の本来の生き方ですね
こちらで言っているのは
その本来の生き方が汚れている生き方として生きているんです
本来の生き方をするためには
特別な訓練は要りません
猫はね ネズミをかけていくような感じで
それは猫の本来の生き方なんですね
そういうことで この動物の世界を見ると
猿は猿たちの本来の生き方で生きているし
他の動物も自分たちの本来の生き方をしているんですね
特別な訓練はしていないんです
特別な訓練させると少々違うことをさせることはできますけどね
そういうことができるならば
やっぱり動物にもすごい高い価値がつくんでしょうね
本来と違ったことをできるならば
それが動物たちに何か芸とか何とか教えるためにはね
かなり苦労しますよ  [咳]言っただけではやらないんです
だからすごい小さい時からもう飼って育てて
毎日毎日毎日 朝も昼も夜ももう一日も欠かす欠かさず訓練させるんですよ
動物たちには 何か芸を見せたければ
一日二日は忘れちゃうと
もう全部忘れてるんです
だからこのそれでも何かできるようになったら
もうこれで大したもんで
もう結構その動物には結構価値がついてきますね
それで人間にしたっても価値がついてくるのは
この本来の生き方を調教して別な生き方に変える時なんですね
だから猿と同じくね 猿にもいろいろ芸を教えるのは大変難しいしね
人間の場合はなおさら難しいんですよ
調教させるっていうことは
で しかし だから諦めると何も意味がないんですね
だから自分の人生は全部諦めたことになるんです
この調教する場合はね
なんで動物より人間が難しいというと
やっぱり動物は余計なことを考えてないんですね
自分の日常の生き方以外は
あまりもう何も考えてない
その中でいろいろ訓練させるんですよ
それが違うんだとかね
それが嫌だとか あんまり考えることできなくなる
嫌っていうことはありますけど
もう飼ってる人だから嫌と言える状態じゃないんですね
日本でも猿のグループをね
持って芸をやって商売やってる人がいるんですけど
やっぱり小さい猿をすごい小さい時からも飼ってね
噛み付くんですね その人は猿を
何のことなく 子供の猿をものすごくきつく
痛く噛み付いちゃうと
もう猿の世界ではもう噛んだ人がボスなんです
だからあの人は人間なんですけど
自分の商売道具であるのに
猿の方はね 嫌でもないしね
可愛いと思ってるし しかし
子供を取ってものすごいキツく
もうもう泣き出すんですね
猿が ギューッと噛むんです
で それは人間見たらなんとことをするのかとかね
なんで動物虐待するのかとかいうあるかもしれませんだけど
やっぱりそれは猿の世界の道徳
決まりでボスは噛みますね
噛んで自分の力を見せるんですね
それでその小さな猿が
この人はおっかないと
この猿はもうボスだと
言う通りにしなくちゃいけないんだということになるんですね
猿にとっても自分が猿で
これは人間という区別はないんだからね
あまり自分の体は鏡で見たりもしないしね
だから外に見えるものはそのまま受け取っているんだからね
だからそれでいろいろ調教すると
もう嫌であってもやったりはする
やらないでやめちゃうとまずいことになります
そうやってもすごく苦労して
猿にいろんな芸を教えて
しかし ろくな芸にはならないんだから
その人はずっと自分の言葉でごまかすんですね
猿の回し見ている人々は
結局あの人の話を聞いているだけで
実際何も猿が何も大したことはやってないんです
で だからその人はずっとストーリーを喋ってるんですね
猿がなんかに乗っているとか
それぐらいのことなんです
逆立ちするとか なんとかとか
人間の調教は最も難しいんですね
人間も調教すると 猿と同じくすっごく脅してやらないとね
脅されていると 何とか言う通りにはする
だから結構欲求不満度かなり惨めなんですね
人間の生き方っていうのはね
いろんな法律でいろんなしきたりで
いろんなところで我々はものすごく脅迫されている
それが怖いんだから 私たちはまともな人間で生活しようとするんです
怖くないと思ったら まあものすごい恐ろしい人間になっちゃうんだ
だから普通におとなしく生活する人間は立派でしょうかっていうか
もうただ脅しに抑えられてるだけなんですね
この間ね ドイツで学校でね
ある十六歳ぐらいの青年がね
十七人殺してしまった
まあ十七人じゃないんですけど
十人ぐらいですね まあそれから警察と撃ち合いになってから
また何人か死んでますけど
それは誰の鉄砲で撃ったかっていうことは言わないんですね
で その若者が一応学校に入って
先生も生徒さん何人か殺してしまったんです
だからそういうことできるのは怖くないと思った瞬間なんですね
社会のこと気にするか
だからその人は精神的な病気もありましたし
まあなんか自分のホームページではね
自分のことは誰も認めてないんだ
自分の能力は誰も知らないとか
何とかことを書いたこともあったあっただそうで
だからこの社会を私は気にするもんかっていうことになっちゃうんで
相手にするなと それで社会を相手にしない
気にもしないと思っちゃうと
もうそういう縦横無尽乱射事件なんかは
まあいとも簡単にできるんですよ
だからこの世の中っていうのは
人間と一緒にいるっていうことはとても危険なことでもありますよ
どんな人にでも どんな酷いことでもできるんです
社会はハチャメチャにすることはできますよ
一人一人人間には いとも簡単に何人でも殺してしまうことはできます
ちょこっと工夫すれば
しかし やらないっていうことがあるんですね
それが恐怖感にいわゆる脅されているだからなんです
だから猿とどこら辺違うでしょうかっていうことは
ちょっとわからなくなるんですね
そこで私が言いたいところは
この調教っていうのは
いかに難しいかっていうことなんです
そう簡単に はい よくわかりました
よく学びますとかね そうはならないんですね
人間にしてみれば もう必ずもう人には頑固だとかなんとか言うんだけどね
自分ほど頑固な者はいるのかっていうね
どんな人でもものすごい頑固ですね
人の話は聞かないんですね
だから自分が思ったことを
自分が言ったことを 自分がやったことっていうのは自分の判断で
それは変えようとはしないんです
若者は年寄りにはすごい頑固だと悪口言ってるでしょうに
当然年寄りは人を言うことを聞かないんですけど
だから若者に頑固呼ばわりするんですよ
私は言うのは じゃあ若者は言うことを聞くのかと
言うことを素直に聞く若者
誰かいるんですかね？一番頑固なのは若者たちでしょうに
社会で 大人の社会で 経験のある社会でいろんなことを言ってるでしょうに
これが良くない これが良くない
あれが良くないとか一つも聞いてないんです
一つも聞いてない 自分のやりたい放題のことをやってるんですよ
子供にしても同じことで
自分のやりたいことだけやってるんであって
恐ろしく頑固なんです
なのに大人に向かって大人が頑固だと
親父はすごく頑固だと
話は聞いてくれないんだと
どちらでしょうかと 親父は息子の話を聞いてあげたら
親父は頑固じゃないということになるんですかね
脅したら聞いてあげますよ
殺すぞとか何とか言うと
父は息子の話は聞くかもしれませんし
だから息子はなんで父親の話を聞かないんですかね
逆に 自分の話を聞けということでしょうに
それは頑固じゃないんですかね
だからもうそこまで頭が悪いんですよ
ただ単純に言葉使うだけで
子供の時からもね ものすごく気持ち悪いほど頑固で
話は通じませんし 子供にでももうちょこっとした
まあ仕来りを理解してもらい
理解しなくてはダメでしょうに
挨拶を学ばなくてはダメでしょうに
行儀作法を学ばなくてはダメでしょうに
それを教えるためにどれほど苦労するのかと
だからそれが人間の本来の姿なんですよ
微塵もちょっとでも美しいところはないんです
だから人間はもうどう頑張ってもなかなか成長するっていうことは見えませんね
そこでこの成長する道はお釈迦様しか語ってないし
世間ではいろんな話があるんだけど
人の役に立つ話っていうのは
ブッダの教え以外はまずないんですね
いくら調べても調べてもないんですね
宗教っていうのはもう恐ろしい頑固な世界で
俺の話を聞きなさい これが神の言葉であると
それで話が終わりですね
あれほど頑固な言葉があるのかと
人間に考える自由さえも奪っちゃうんです
自分で判断するという
それさえも奪うんですね
だから人間自分で判断しても頑固な判断なんですけど
それも奪って極限に束縛される
極限に束縛されて極限に恐怖
脅迫するんですね 永遠な地獄に落ちるんだと
それで このとてつもない頑固な人の話を聞くこと
それが成長ですかと 人類の
これは神の言葉といういい加減なことをでたらめ言う人がどれほど嘘をついているのかということもあるでしょうに
だから自分の頑固を通じるためにどこまでインチキ詐欺やってるのかと
だからもう絶対もう親は自分のこと心配しているんだから
親に対していするのもってのほかですけど
親はたとえ頑固であろうとも
全く話通じなくても 子供のことを心配するんだからね
ちょっとだけでも話聞いた方がいいと思いますけど
しかし 神の言葉持ってくる連中はそう心配してますか？人間のこと
いかに自分の話を通じて自分が支配者になって
自分がもう奴隷にする人々に
その気持ちでそういう話をしたりしている
それで極限に脅して 反論の自由も奪って
思考の自由も奪って で
極限に脅して 自分言う通りにやってもらうと
それから立派な人間だと言ったりするんですけど
それではね 人間には何の成長もないんですよ
退化以外何でもないんですね
だから信仰的な宗教がね
社会で広げると そのすぐその社会は退化するんです
人殺し いくらでも起こるんですね
今も最近でもね 世の中を見てみると
いろんな国々でね もうどこかの国でこの
シャリアなんとかってイスラムのコーランの法律システムがありまして
そこはもう法律にしますということに決めたと
なぜかというと あまりにもテロ行為がありすぎちゃって
それはもうかなわないんだから
その原理主義者がね 原理主義者は平気で人を殺したり
テロ行為やったりする
それで原理主義者が怖いんだから
では純原理主義になりましょうと
それで普通の人間が作った法律ではなくて
コーランで書いたとてつもない恐ろしい法律を法律にする
コーランが神の言葉だから
あんなのはもう読んだらあかんということになるんですね
すごい怖いってことになるんですね
やっぱり俺の話聞けという態度だからね
人間作る法律は決して悪い思考はないんだけど
不完全ですけど それなりに人間に反論することはできるし
戦うこともできるし 自由があるんですね
法律の中でもそれがなくなるんですね
盗んだら手を切断しなさいと宗教法律で書いているならば
それは何とかしましょうとできませんよ
何とかしましたら もうもう神の言葉に逆らったことになるんだから
だからこの そういう風に信仰宗教ですね
信仰というのは信仰するという意味の信仰です
で 絶対的信仰をするというふうなことの宗教を広げると
世の中にはもう人殺しやらテロ行為やら不公平なことやら
もうものすごく起こっちゃうんだよね
差別っていうのはきりがなく起こってしまうんです
平和には 幸福になりません
それから 信奉はそれっきりで終わりです
そこでこの この黒い悪い生き方をやめて
良い生き方 理性のある人がするんだよと
理性っていうことはわざと入れているんですよ
ブッダの言葉っていうのはすごい完全たる言葉だから
訂正できないんですね
異論成り立たないんですね
人間はそうするべきであると言っても
お釈迦様は真理を知っているんだからね
理性のあるという一言葉を入れるのです
だからお釈迦様には誰もかなわないんです
理性のある人が この本来の生き方を何とかしてやめて
正しい生き方をしようとするんですね
生き方というのは正しい思考をする
正しい言葉を喋る 正しい行いをする
残念ながらこの教えは
この偈はね 出家している比丘たちに言う偈なんですね
在家の方々のことはあまり考えてないんです
ですから この出家するっていうことで生き方が変わるはずなんです
出家していかに在家のことをごまかしてやるのかというふうに考える出家もいないわけじゃないんだけど
出家したらもう在家の生き方っていうのは 1つもやらないんですね
何でもかんでも違うとするんです
考え方も変わる 変えるんです
このように考えるべきだということまであるんですね
出家したら 毎日の行為はね
これこれはいいんだけど
これこれはダメですよと
本来の生き方はもうできないんです
喋る場合も本来の喋りはできないんですね
禁止されているんです
だからこの それをわかってない人々は
この出家組織が現代社会に適応できるようにいろいろ改良しなくちゃいけないんだとか
何とか言ったりするんですけど
何言ってるんでしょうかね
現代社会に適応できるように改良するとか
それだったら現代社会は完璧な社会という意味でしょうね
それだったらそもそも出家する意味もないでしょうに
なんで完璧な社会から脱出するんですかね
だから人間の思考っていうのは
いくらなんでも腐ってるんです
何の役にも立たないんです
出家したのは 在家社会にいろいろ欠陥があるんだからでしょう
それで在家世界に適応できるように
いろいろ自分たちの生き方を改良すると
一般人がみんな酒飲んでるんだから
じゃあ出家も酒飲んだ方がいいんじゃないかとか
みんな結婚しているんだから
出家も結婚するべきだと
妻帯するべきだと 結局はお釈迦様がおっしゃったせっかくの道を壊しちゃったんです
ちょっとしたことで仏教はそのままもう壊してしまうんですね
そこはどこでとても恐ろしいこと
なぜならば それで他の人々には何も学ぶことがなくなっちゃうんです
だから 未来の人類まで不幸に陥れるということになるんです
そんなのは歴史的な事実ですからね
自分たちだけ地獄に落ちるんじゃなくて
これから生まれる全ての生命にも道を閉ざしてやるぞということになるんです
ブッダが悟りましたからね
知恵を完成したんだからね
微塵も知恵開発してない人に改良できるんですかね
その教えは 改良できないんですよ
自分に分からなくなっちゃうと
お釈迦様間違ってると思うんですね
いい理屈ですよ 先生の授業わからないと
先生がよく勉強してないんだと
私がそこを直してあげると
自分にわからないって
相手のせいにするという
えらい学者なんですね
仏教の偉い開祖様たちがそんな程度なんです
まあ病気ですから 別に怒らなくてもね
私は怒ってないんですけど
病気ですからしょうがないんです
それでこのお釈迦様が
理性のある人が観難ダンマン
暗い黒い生き方をやめて
須観ダンマン 白い 汚れてない生き方をすると
理性がないとできないんですよ
だからポイントはこのパンリトウ
パンリトウっていうのは理性のある人という意味で理解した方がよろしいと思います
賢者という風にも日本訳しますが
理性のある人 だから理性で考えるところは
私はずっと喋って終わりました
猿の話とかいろいろ持ってきたのは理性で見る方法なんです
理性で誰でも上京し 誰でも学びますよとか
そんなこと迂闊に言える場合じゃないんです
誰でも脅しがなければやりませんだから
学校に行くことも学ぶことも脅しがあるんだからでしょうに
なんで子供は宿題やるんですかね
やらなかったら最悪状態になるんだから
これ怖いんですよ だからもう怖さで怯えて生きてるんだから
えらいかっこいいんですね
脅されて イスラム教でも一部の人々はテロ行為やってますけど
イスラムの人々みんな悪い人間というわけじゃないんです
ごく普通の人間ですけど
一部はテロ行為やったりして
それで自分の国でもテロリストがいて
そちらイスラム教じゃないんですね
キリスト教なんで だから教会の祝福にあって
一生懸命テロ行為をやめているんです
しかし 聖書ではね テロ行為をやったら天国に行くという話はないんです
だからそこは言えないんです
その代わり何するのかというと
この お母さんやらお父さんやらね
逮捕するんです テロリストを捕まって連れて行くんです
言ったら娘さんとかね
若いとかいるでしょうね
その人に親を話して欲しければこういうことをやらなくちゃいけないと
やったらもう 親を話してあげる
もしテロ行為しなかったら
あんた断るならば あなたこの場で撃ち殺すし
親も殺すんだと あなたの目の前で
そうすると その女の子たちが
やっぱり女であろうか
男であろうがもね 家族を守りたいという気持ちが出てくるんだから
では私が死にますと 死んで家族を守ってあげると
いうことで いろんなところでテロ行為をやっている
そこの場合でも よく見えることっていうのは
恐ろしく脅されているでしょ
そこは教会はもう新聞記事書くんですね
これぐらいこの人々を仏教徒たちにいじめられているんだと
だから自爆テロやってるんだと
大体自爆テロが起こる前に新聞記事は出ているので回っているんです
同時に出るんですね 時間のズレがないっていうのは面白いんです
大体どこかで事件が起きて
まあそれニュースで流れると時間かかりますけどね
見事な記事が出ているんですよ
記事を書くためには 1週間ぐらいかかるぐらい色々情報が集めたりしてね
大体記事が先に書くんです
それで記事に適した事件を起こす
起こさせるんですね だからこのそれがこの生命を愛しなさいという宗教がやってるんです
で テロリストは最終的に終了したいと軍隊は考えているんですけど
だいたい 1  2時間でできます
できますけど この一般人がたくさん強引に引っ張られて盾に使っているんですね
食べ物もないんです それは一般人が誰が集めてあげたかというと
教会なんです だから私がすごくこういうのを仏教とは言ってはいけないことなんで
他宗教を批判するのはね
仏教をやってはいけないことになってますが
やっぱり信仰するというね
ことになるとろくな結果がないっていうことですね
人類にとっては 差別 差別ばっかしで
みんな仲良く人間でしょうということでね
人間でしょ 人間であるならばいろいろありますけど
まあそんなことを気にしないで生活しますということはね
兄弟も喧嘩するし 夫婦も喧嘩するし
人間だから だからといってね
お互い殺し合いやるんですかね
喧嘩もしながら異論も言い張りながら仲良く生活することでしょうね
それぐらいのことできないんですね
人間ならいろいろ考えはある
いろいろ信仰もあるかもしれませんしね
色は違うし 言語は違うし
だから だからそれで殺し合いやるんですかね
なんでそういう理屈作るんですかね
人間が同じ言語を喋るべきであるならば
我々本来同じ言語を喋るでしょうに
同じ神を信仰するべきだったらね
人間は本来その神というアホのことを知ってるでしょうに
なんで神がたくさんいるんですかね
ということは人間勝手に作ることでしょう
ということは 人間 10人いれば 10タイプの神を作れますよ
皆様にもできますよ 絶対的神様の名前は田中やら一郎やら何とかとかね
ヤハウェではないんだぞとかね
その神はこんなもんだ
こんなもんだとかね いくら簡単にできるでしょう
もし絶対的神 1匹がいるならば
我々みんなそれ知ってるはずなんです
1匹というのはどんな風に数えればいいかわからないんですね
要するに人間じゃないんだからね
1匹 2匹と数えなくちゃいけないんです
何匹いるんです わがまま好き勝手な存在でしょうに
自分で殺したければいくらでも殺すんだから
やっぱり人間じゃないんですね
日本の神は体で稼いでますけどね
日本の神っていうのはたくさんいるし
恐ろしくはないんですけどね
だから一人しか神がいないと言ったって
それは人間勝手に言うことで
八百万の神がいると言ったって
それで人間が勝手に言うことで
人間にそんなこと言えるんだから
それが人間でしょうに
それによって人を殺すべきでしょうかね
それも話は矛盾だらけでしょうね
だけどそれもすっごい頑固ということなんですね
我は思うことだけ正しいと
私が考えて生き方だけが正しいと
みんな私の話を聞けと
私はあなた方の話聞きませんよと
あなた方喋るならば殺すんだぞという話なんです
そうすると他の人に同じ権利が生じるんだから
いえ 私は違う考え方を持ってますけど
私の考え方だけ正しいんだと
あなたは私の話を聞けない
いえ あなたは私の話を聞きなさい
またお互いに殺そう じゃあ私も殺そうということになっているんです
それで世の中で殺し合いとか
いろんなことができてしまするんですね
だからそちらに必要な理性っていうことなんですよ
理性で見れば 何のことないんです
神がいてもいなくてもどうでもいいんです
理性のある人にとっては
ある人が私はもうなんだらかんだら名前のアフラマスだという名前の神が信仰しています
その神こそ絶対神 はい
どうぞ で終わりますから
はい どうぞご自由に信仰してください
何か助けてあげることでもありますかと
神にお祈りするとき 何か必要だったら
あなたなかったら私は揃ってあげますよと
それが理性のある人の生き方なんですよ
だからお釈迦様にしたっても
私の神様には生贄が必要やと
じゃあ人を それはやめてくださいと
殺す権利ないんだと誰にでも
ブッダがそれだけには反対するんです
人間でも動物でも生贄にするなよと
どう見たっても生命苦しめたらいじめたらもういい結果にはなるはずがないんだと
信仰するのはどうぞご自由にと
果物とか米とかお供えするならば
それは構いませんと それで仏教の人々に別な思考があるんだからね
この気持ち悪いご飯食べる神って大したことはないんだと
あとお供えするもの見てください
人間にも食べられない状況だから
今日テレビでね 神様に大根をお供えするとかね
大根だけ食っちゃったらね
人間は食べませんだけどね
でもそれぐらいは文句言う必要はかえってないしね
本人が大根をお供えしたいんだならば
自分の信仰してる神様が大根ばっか食ってるならば
まあそれはしょうがないでしょうね
で こちらも挨拶に行く場合は
大根 1本持っていけば話はそれで平和で終わりますよ
だって樽ごとにお酒をお供えする神社もあるでしょうに
相当な酔っ払いでしょうね
だからまあ清らかではなくて
何て言いますか 清めでしたっけ
お祓いですからね まあ理屈ないわけじゃない
酒っていうのはかなり
あの 何て言いますか あの
消毒する薬として使いますからね
樽ごとに酒に進まなくちゃあかん神っていうのはね
結構最近の方かもしれませんしね
それでもそれはその方々の考え方で
それは人間だからね いろんなことを考えるんでしょうね
それで我々理性があったら
もうあなたも一緒に参加してくださいと言うと
まあ樽 1つはちょっと高すぎだから
瓶 1本ぐらいは持っていったってもうね
そんなに高いお金ではないしね
それは何のことのないんですよ
何の罰も当たりませんよ
かえっていいことです
なぜならば 社会の秩序
平和 調和を守っているんだから
だから 酒を 1滴も飲まないという決まり守っている人でも
もう酒しか飲まない神様のところに友達に言われて行く場合は
酒 1瓶ぐらい持っていくのはね
決して悪行為ではないんですよ
理性で考えれば それは良い行為なんです
それで人間が仲良くなるんです
差別がなくなるんです
理性っていうのはそういうものなんです
理性で考えると この私はこの本来という言葉はもう最近ちょっと使ってみようかなと思ったんですね
なぜならば この大乗仏教では
この本来という言葉はよく人気あるんですね
本性という言葉はよく人気あるんですね
人間だけじゃなくて あまりにも尊いんですね
その本来の姿に戻るべきですということで
我らの本性は仏性であり
仏性ですけどね 発音微妙にちょっと違うだけでね
で あれもわかってないんですよ
本性って最悪なんです
最低最悪なんです 人間本性に戻してみてください
これから子供を産む予定の明るい方々いるならば
子供が生まれたら何も教えないで
そのままご飯だけ ミルクだけあげてください
ミルクの元からミルクをあげて
それで固形物を食べるようになったらそれを食べさせて
病気になったら治療してあげて
寒くなったら服を着させてあげて
他何も教えない 本性で本来の姿で育ちますよと
幼稚園に行かせてはならない
幼稚園は本来の姿じゃないんです
人工的な環境だから 学校にも行かせてはならん
言葉とか教えてはならんです
言葉っていうのは人間が作ったもんだからね
それで本来の姿がなくなっちゃいます
だから言語も別に教えないで
本人勝手に学ぶならばどうぞ勝手にということで
どうなるんですかと 本性で育てると
猿よりも気持ち悪い恐ろしい存在になるんです
[背景音楽]だからそこは理性で見ると僕わかるはずなんですよ
生まれたまんまでは大変やと
あのオオカミ少年といういろいろストーリーあるんですね
時々あれは本当の話やってこともあるんですけどね
なんかインドではなんかどこかで森の中でいた子とも捕まって
でもあまりにも怖くて噛み付く人間攻撃
それで檻に入れちゃって
で なんとかっていう話もあります
それもオオカミ少年ではなくて
まああのもう虎に育てられたっていうことでね
虎が子供育てるかどうかちょっとわかりにくいんだけどね
虎ってね 赤ちゃん見たら食べるかもしれませんだけどね
まああんまり動物は人間の肉は食べないんです
すっごくまずいんだそうです
私は聞いてはないんだから
あんまり真面目に聞かない方がいいんです
虎に聞いたことはないんですけど
人間肉は美味しいか虎がまずいと言ったら
お前食べたことあるのかということもありますからね
一応あのイギリス人がね
動物をすごく愛するんだから
ジーン・カベルという人がこの虎を殺すんですよ
で かなり前なんで 本書いてるんで
どれを自分がどのように虎を殺したんですか？たくさん殺してるんです
そちらで彼がもう虎狩りに行って
まあそれで人々をも頼むもんですね
まあそこまでで まあこの 50年前の話です
だからその当時は虎がいっぱいいましたから
インドではね で 人を襲ったら
攻撃したら もうみんなもうその人言わなくたって
その人はさっさとあの虎を殺してやるぞってことで
色々計画立てて  1匹1匹虎を殺した話をあの
あの結構分厚い本に書いてるんですよ
その人がまあ言うのは
この人間攻撃する虎っていうのはまず年寄りだと
で 歯が落ちてるんだと
1つ条件 あの牙 4本とかあります
それすごく大事なんですね
それが壊れたり落ちたりすると
もうもう死ぬしかないんですよ
獲物取れないんです だから人間お腹が空いちゃうと
もうやむをえず 走る能力もないと気持ち悪いでしょうね
やっぱり追っかけてきて攻撃するのはね
気分がいいんでしょうし
噛んでも逃げるっていうことは
おそらくすごい気分がいいと思いますよ
時々もう虎とかね もう噛みつくんだけど
獲物がそれでももう攻撃して逃げちゃうという場合もあります
それで失敗しました 商売はもう赤字になったとか
もう動物は思わないんですね
なるほど その競争世界はそんなことだ知ってるんです
これ 何の競争もなく もう行った
取っただけ 人間の場合は走れないでしょうね
走れる人間であっても頭が悪いんだから
怯えてあってもう漏らしたりしてそのまま倒れるでしょ
虎を見ると だから虎にもただ食べればいいっていい話なんです
だからあの人气の論理で
だから虎にしてみれば一番もうプライド傷つく一番面子を立てないことだと
人間攻撃することは それである若い虎が人間攻撃して何人殺して
この人 そのもう虎を狩りに行って
彼が喋ると 村人はみんなもうこの人を笑ったと
違いますよと あれはもう若い虎やと
あんた言ってるのは年寄りじゃないんだと
だからあなたの論理は成り立たないんだと
この人は何かあるはずですよと
でないと人間は襲うはずないんだと
何か狩りできないことがあるはずだと言って
一応その虎を取ったんです
そしたら本当にもう若くて元気
ものすごい元気な虎で
村人にもすごくからかわれて笑われたんだ自分が
それで虎を皮を剥がすんですね
皮を剥がしていくと 足ものすごく化膿してうみがいっぱい中に入った
それで調べたら 針ネズミというんですか
でっかい動物いますね
針いっぱい持っている
で あれ美味しいんだそうですよ
虎なんかハリネズミ見たらもう食べてやろうと思っちゃうんですね
で それでだいたい若い虎たちは一番この食べにくい殺しにくいハリネズミに挑戦するんです
で ハリネズミはもう攻撃するんですね
逆に針が立てたら小さく顔しか見えません
大きいんですよ ハリネズミも結構
で 熱食分ぐらい 2 日間ぐらいはもう食べるものはあります
捕まったら そこで針が簡単に抜けるんですね
それでこの針 1つ刺しちゃって刺したところで針の先っぽが落ちるんです
で 皮膚の中に入って そこはずっと化膿する
それでもうどんどん体意識して化膿してうみがたまっていて
もう動かないんで手が足が
外から見ればすごいピカピカの怪我傷跡は見えません
外は直してますけど 中が針が残ってるんだからね
そういうことでしたと
だから 何ですかね まあ人間をあまり動物は食べないということになっています
そういう理由で じゃあ理性の
話に戻りますけど 人間というのは本来の姿
本性というところになると
動物よりもものすごい恐ろしくてかっこ悪いということになるんです
で 人間頭があるんだからね
科学やらいろんなものを発展しましたと自慢するんだけど
いかに地球に迷惑かと
いかに人類に迷惑かと
いかに他の生命に迷惑かというと切りがないでしょう
大量破壊兵器なんか誰が開発するんですかね
人間でしょうね 動物は一度も大量に動物を殺してやろうと思ったことは一度もないでしょうに
わけもなく殺すぞということ全くないでしょうに
日本にいる凶暴なスズメバチでも人間見たら襲うぞってことないでしょうに
敵対する理由があると攻撃するんであって
人間どうですかね わざと殺すために理屈作るんです
自分の理屈を認めなさいと
北朝鮮が何かミサイル
何て言うのは何て言いますか
あれは え？発射するでしょ
それにもう世界は知ってますけど
これは単純にこの原子爆弾を投げてあっちこっちもうもうそのテストなんですけど
いえ これは衛星を打ち上げるんだと
そう言うと ああそうですか
よく分かりました 世界はバカにならなくちゃいけないんですね
はい それは合法的に賛成しますと言わなくちゃいけないんですよ
もし誰がそれを撃ち落としたら
もう国に対して戦争をしたことにしますよという脅しまであったりして
だから世界はみんな北朝鮮に怖くならなくちゃいけないんですね
えらい態度ですね 結局我は言うことは正しい
あなた方は信じなさいという話ですよ
では人間正しいことを言うんですかね
自分の都合で物事を言うんです
それが本来の姿なんです
それで大乗仏教ってすごい人気ある
この本来の姿という考え方はなぜ出てきたということは
あの仏教をいろいろ学んだりすると
仏教でいろんなことは生き方を教えてるんですよ
ブッダが完璧に喋ってますから
異論できないんですよ
あ これが正しい生き方やとわかるんです
わかるんだけど 自分ではやらないんですね
嘘をついてはならないと知っているんだけど
嘘つくんです 怒ってはなりませんと知ってはいるんだけど
怒るんです そうすると仏教を学ぶ人は
あれ 私はたまたま怒ったんであって
あれ本来の気持ちじゃないんだと言うんです
社会の常識に合わせて酒を飲むんであって
仏教徒の本来の姿ではないんだと
本来の姿は仏性であると
自分を正当化するだけの話です
それならどんな悪いこともできますから
本来の姿じゃないんだからね
本来みんなブッダですと
だから我々がやっていることは全部もう本来の姿ではなくて
仮の あるいは幻覚 だったらいいんでしょ？別に
なんかね 神話物語読んで楽しいでしょ
別にそんなことはありえないと知っているし
楽しいだけ 楽しくなるだけだから
もう何の問題もないでしょう
空を飛ぶ絨毯がある話を読んで
はぁよかった楽しかったとかね
問題は本当に空を飛ぶ絨毯があると思っちゃうと
もう薬飲まなくちゃいけない病になるんですね
ただ あれって面白いストーリーだよと
本を読んだりするのは決して悪くないし
漫画描くのも アニメーション描くのは決して悪くないんですよ
そんな感じで人間の本来の姿ではないんだから
嘘をついたっても 人を殺したっても
何やったっても 本来はいい人間だよと
だからこの本来の姿という言葉が出てきたのは
私たちと何の関わりもないんで
我々もいろんな悪いことをして
それはもうもうその時もうスイスイやっただけで
私はそんな悪い人間じゃないんだよという気持ちでしょ
いつでも自分を正当化するんですよ
悪いこと言ったらなんて情けないかと自分がと
反省はしませんね いい人間でいるつもりですけど
なんだこれはと ちょっとしたことでとんでもないことをやるんじゃないかと
やっぱり私は育ててないんだと
いうふうに見るのが仏教的な見方なんです
情けないんだよ こんなの
だから一個でも悪いことはしないのが正しいんだと
だから本性本性と戦うことが理性の道なんですよ
本性をクタクタ潰すことが理性の道なんです
本性が善悪であるならば
真っ暗であるならば それは完全に壊すんです
残りなく それで真っ白いの新たな自分が現れるはずなんです
その人もすっごく自然に生きているんです
我々は自然に生きていると悪いことしか何もやりませんよ
だから 私たちにとっては良いことをするのは難しいし
ストレス溜まるんですよ
嘘をつかないということに決めるともう大変ですよ
苦しいんです 盗まない
金ごまかさない 不正に収入を得ませんとかね
思って生きてみるともう大変苦しいんです
生き方は やりたい放題やるぞと思ったら結構気楽なんです
それが本来の姿なんですよ
だから 良いことをしようとする我々は結構苦しむんですよ
本性と戦わなくちゃいけないんです
もし本性が跡形もなく壊れたらどうなるんですかね
誰と戦うことないでしょう
その人は本性で素直にストレスなく穏やかに生きている
しかし 微塵も悪いことは起こり得ません
だから 善悪は悟りに達した人にはないんです
私たちにはあるんです
本性に従っちゃうと悪
自分の本性本性と戦っちゃうと善
だから我々は善悪のもう戦場に巻き込まれているんですよ
もうあちらからこちらから撃たれているんです
誰の鉄砲で死ぬかわからないんです
味方の鉄砲でするか 敵の鉄砲でするかわからない状態でいるんですよ
良いことをしようと思ったところで
まあもしかすると社会に潰されるかもしれませんし
悪いことしたところで社会に潰される可能性もあるし
大変です そこで本性を壊してしまえば
悪が全て死んじゃったんです
そこで本性としてあるのは善なんです
もう戦いはないんです
悟った人は本性で生きているんです
悟った人は喋りたいものを喋るんです
考えたいものを考えるんです
行いたいことを行うんです
しかし それは全て完璧な行為なんです
それでお釈迦様が悟りに達する人は
善も悪も乗り越えているんだと言うんですね
それでまた本性が良くない人々はその言葉だけ
盗むんです 意味は理解してないんです
言葉を盗んで悟ったら何でもできるんだと
だから悟った人は人を殺しても罪に問えないんだと思って
人殺しまで命令命令する
それは日本でよくあった出来事だからね
我は最終解脱したと思ったりして
人を騙して人殺しまで命令する
人殺しで悟った人には関係ないんだと言うんです
言って偉業をするんです
恐ろしい盗みですよ それで私に言われたら
私の仏教の解釈が間違っているんだと
これはもう最終解脱の解説信じなさいと
私は頑固だから信じていなかったんですね
むちゃくちゃ攻撃してたんです
今も時々あんた方が仏教でブッダがいるんだから
日本で信じてはどうですかと
言われますけど 私は頑固だからね
結構ですと あの人はブッダだけじゃなくて神でもあるでしょうと
そうですよと だったらあいつにこの何か小さな川でもいいんだから
説教に入れ替えるようにしてください
日本が困っているんだよと
なんであいつは人のご飯食ってるんですか？神でありながら
全知全能の 日本人ぐらい助けてあげたって罰が当たらないでしょうに
人助けひとかけらもしないで
我は全知全能の神であると言うんです
だから我の俺の話を聞けっていうことでしょう
だから人間には理性がないんですよ
言う人にはないのは当たり前で
怖いんです 人間は 理性でいれば
宗教も信仰も何も要らなくなりますよ
正しく生きているんです
平和で 社会秩序を守って
それで社会も良くしながら
柔軟性があって 余裕があって
要領があって生きていられます
はい そういうことで このこの芸の1行しか説明できないんだから
私は結構 2行になったらもうかなわないぐらい難しいんです
私は説明できないとは言いたくはないんだから
私も頑固だからね 解説はできますよ
一番簡単に見える一行の意味はそんな意味なんです
そういうことで 我々私たちは今日は何か覚えておかないとね
困りますからね で 悪いことをしないで良いことをしましょうというのは
こんなもう誰にでも子供にでもわかる話やと思っちゃうんだけど
そんなものじゃない 理性という言葉が入っているんです
理性のある人は 悪い生き方をやめて良い生き方をするんだと
これがとてつもなく難しいことなんです
だから挑戦するんです
本性とは戦うんですよ
本性とは戦うことがかっこいいんです
怒りの感情が出てきたら言いたい放題のことを言うっていうことはかっこいいわけじゃないんです
怒りがこみ上げたにも関わらず
怒りを抑え 収めようたと
怒ったんだけど 一言葉も悪い言葉を発しなかったと
我慢しましたと 自分をコントロールしましたと
それがすごいかっこいいことなんです
嘘をついて逃げたくなったんだけど
嘘をつかなかったと いとも簡単に金ごまかすことできたのにやらなかったと
それがすごいかっこいい生き方なんです
それに挑戦してほしいと
だから今できないことに挑戦することで人は成長していくんです
この成長の最後何なのか
では私は一体どうなるのかっていうところは 2行目のことなんです
そこであれにこれに依存して生きているんです
我々は肉体に依存しているんです
目 耳 鼻の刺激に依存しているんです
自分の汚れた思考に依存しているんです
その依存 このものが命ということなんです
生きるということなんです
だから生きること自体も悪なんです
しかし 生きることは止められないんです
死んでも止まらないんです
死んだというのは体が肉体が壊れただけの話で
感情の流れは流れるんです
今も肉体と関係なく感情が別々に独立して行動するんだから
依存していますけど 別にも行動することはできます
人に何か言われたら怒ることはできます
何も言わなくたっても怒ることはできるんです
人間と仲良くすると嫉妬が生まれてくることもありますよ
でなくても 勝手にいろんなことを妄想してぐちゃぐちゃ嫉妬作ることもできます
例えばドイツで人を殺した人にしたってもう精神的にイカれていて
家に閉じこもれていて
それで勝手に世の中のことを自分で妄想して
もうとてつもない怒りを作って 17
人ぐらい殺してしまっちゃった
何の関係もない人と だから感情は自分勝手に行動することはとても簡単なんです
どちらかというとその方が強いんです
我々は理由があって怒るよりは
理由がなくなくのにも関わらず
ずっと怒りっぱなしで怒り屋さんで生活するんですよ
嫉妬の人がもう訳があってもなくてもすごい嫉妬深いんです
欲が深いと思う 小さい時からもうその性格なんです
赤ちゃんたち見てください
生まれた時はもう何も理由なく性格を持ってるんですね
もうちょっとしたことに怒るわ
並の怒りじゃないんですよ
子供が怒るともう発作起こすんですね
何を迷って言いたいんですよ
ここまで親が大事に可愛がっているのに
愛されているのに そんな微妙なことに激怒して
もう体小さいんだからもうどうにもならなくなったりして
だから結局はそれ持ってきたもんなんです
クタクタ社会にいじめられて馬鹿にされて猛烈に怒るということもまた別なんです
だから体が壊れたんだからって万々歳じゃないんですよ
それは人は自分の都合で死んだら終わりやと考えているのは
これは単純に我は思うことだけ正しいという話しか何ともないんです
だからこの感情 心 思考っていうのは独立して変化していくんですね
ものすごく肉体に依存していますけど
独立して行動できる だから死んで終わらないんですよ
命は 死んでから悪は終了とか
みんな天国やと 日本ではどんな人間でも死んだら見事に天国に行かせるんですね
この間テレビでなんとか誰かさんのそういうなんとか別れ会を見ていたんですけどね
ごく普通の女の人がもうなんかもう突然死んじゃって
誰も知らなくてね 飯島さんでしたっけ
名前はね 死んでからはみんな泣くわ泣くわ
何の人籍でも何でもないのに
この芸能人の人々はね
芸能界の人 そんなお互い仲良くしないんでしょうしね
それぞれみんな忙しいしね
番組で一緒になるだけなんですよ
涙ポロポロ もしかするとお母さんもそこまで泣いてないと思いますよ
お母さん泣いちゃったら
それは本当の涙なんですけど
もう今まで育てて もうものすごい悪い性格もやっていたんだからね
お母さんしてみればもう大変ですから
泣くどころじゃないかもしれませんし
腹が立ってるかもしれませんしね
言う通りに成長しなかったんだから
そんなことになったんだよと
これは芸能人たちが泣くわ泣くわと
それでもう天国に行かせるんですね
あなた方何様ですかと聞きたいんですよ
やっとこの世の中で生きてるのに
人を天国に はい どうぞ天国に行ってください
いかに人間バカっていうことですよ
人が死んでどうなるのかというと
私たちに管理できますかね
このテーラワーダ仏教っていうのは
なかなか日本の社会に合わないので
我々はもう葬式で喋ったって
もう理性は微塵も崩さないんです
だからこのなんだらかんだら人がもう必ず天国にいると絶対言わないんです
これは日本の社会には合わない言葉かもしれません
人生にブッダの話をするんです
人の将来は行為によって決められるものであると
これ 誰にもどうすることもできんやと
あんたがても泣いていてもね
調子に乗るなよと 人はいつ生まれるか
いつ死ぬか こんなのは誰にもどうすることもできないんだよと
私たちにできることは
せっかく人間に生まれたんだから
悪いことをしないで頑張ることだけでしょうと
もしこの死んだ人もそれなりにいいことをしたならば
まあ将来はいいところに生まれるでしょうと
それでもしやったいいことがあったら
それは一応こういうこういうこともやりましたと
この人はとか あまり悪いことをやったことは言いませんだけど
もし良いことをやったならば
それも言って そういうことで冥福を祈りましょうで終わるんです
話は 冥福を祈るぐらいは悪くはないんですよ
誰が死んじゃっても地獄に行ってくださいっていうのはおかしいですよ
だから 人間の道徳としてとにかく天国に生まれてほしいと期待はする
だけど 生まれるわけじゃないんです
それを覚えておけと 我々の気持ちは天国に生まれてほしいということです
たとえ悪人であっても
天国に行かせるんだからね
このすごい知識社会は
本当に面白いんですね
人間のこの無知ということはね
無知を讃嘆するんですね
はい それで生きるっていうこと自体がかなりやばいんですよ
本性が汚いんだから それで生きるっていうことは依存することなんですね
本性はこんなことに破ったら依存そのものが消えるんです
だから 家から家ない境地に達するんです
それは涅槃という境地なんです
残念ながら それだけは人間には理解できないんです
理解はすべて依存なんです
頭でも理解できないんです
いくら踏ん張っても お釈迦様は理解できないと言ったら理解できないんです
お釈迦様は涅槃の境地に対しては言葉がありませんと言っているんだから
言葉がないんです 言葉がなかったらどうやって理解するんですかね
しかし 言葉がないことでも我々は経験することはできます
経験と言葉という 2つがありまして
最初から人間には言葉ではなくて
聖書だったら最初に言葉があったんですけど
これはヘリクツで経験があるんです
生きている連中には おなかの中ででも経験というものあるんですよ
感じることだから 感じることに後から言葉つけてみるんです
だからどんな だから言語たくさんなるんですよ
いろんなカテゴリーの言葉つけてみるんです
初めから言葉ありきだったら
言葉は 1種類しかないでしょうに
だから初めからももう自分の尾っぽ踏んでるんですね
進めないんです 面白いね
初めから間違った文章から
それからずっと進んでいくんだからね
私は面白く思うのは なんで他の人にその分析できないのかと
私は子供の頃読みましたからね
聖書をすごい子供の頃
初めから言葉ありきで
あれ なんだこれ 納得いかんと
だからずっと終わりまでむさぼって読みますけど
一つも納得はいかないという
それで最終的にはこんなものを信じる人も世の中にいるもんだなぁとかね
変人に見えるんですよ
信じられないんですよ
本当に友達もいますけど
もう神父さんで よくもこういう人々はね
勉強もできるのに よく信じるもんだなと
初めからは矛盾ありきですからね
初めからもちんぷんかんぷんであると
初めからあべこべでありって
コランという本はもっとひどいんですよ
論理構成が ですから 経験というのは大量にあって言葉少ないんです
言葉の数は 今も皆様が経験する全てのものに日本語の単語あるのかというと
いくらでもないものあるんですよ
例えばご飯の味は？味噌汁の味は？知らない？知ってるでしょ
ではご飯の味に 味噌汁の味に言葉を付けてみてください
ないでしょうに ご飯？美味しいですよ
味噌汁？美味しいですよ
いい加減にしろよ 明確な味が違うでしょうに
何言うんですか 味噌汁も美味しい
ご飯も美味しいと だから
そういうことでいっぱい経験はありますよ
ご飯にしたっても 標準米のご飯とやらね
あきたこまちやらね もう本物の
もう我々食べたことはないんですけど
何でしたっけ コシヒカリね
新潟でね そういう人々だけ食べてるんだからね
こちら出す場合は混ぜて混ぜて混ぜて混ぜて
で 一割ぐらいコシヒカリあればコシヒカリなんです
まあとにかく一回コシヒカリ食べたことあるんですよ
私は 新潟で 味が違うんですよ
こちらで食べるご飯とは
違うんだけど 何が違うかと聞いたって知らない
単語がないんです だから
米にしたっても それぞれ種類によって味が違うということは皆様にも経験あるんだけど
単語がないんです それで涅槃のことを説明してくれっていうのはね
これは調子に乗りすぎですね
で 説明しますけど それだったらもうあきたこまちと新潟のコシヒカリと標準米の味の差を言葉で表現してほしいんです
それしてみたら 私は見事によくわかりましたっていうことになったら
涅槃っていうのはこういうものであると私も説明します
あの言葉作られるのに
このご飯の味とかね そういうものには
やっぱり言語能力はそれほど強くないんですよ
何か言葉をつけたっても 「
あれ これどんな意味？」ということになっちゃうんです
何か新語 新語をつけることできますよ
だから出て表現したことにならないんです
うかつに言葉を作っても意味がないんです
[背景の子供の声]そういうことで
言葉には言葉の法則がありましてね
例えば秋田こまちは晴れり味だと
もう新潟の米は利れり味やと言ったら単語でしょ
あれ何の意味ですか？意味がないでしょうに
だから言葉は作れないものは作れないんです
うん それで涅槃についてお釈迦様が言うのは
それは究極の幸福である
それで終わり 話はね 生きることは極限な苦である
だから苦から幸福に達することですよ
ですと で それで理解して精進するんです
このヴィヴェーカという単語は離れるということで
いわゆる依存なくすという単語なんですね
依存をなくすということは
なかなか人間やりたくないんだから
もう一つ単語がありますね
えっと どこですかっけ？ドゥーラマン
ドゥーラマンというのは
ラマティっていうのは喜びます
で ドゥーラマっていうのは喜ぶことはちょっと難しいんだと
だから我々は依存で喜んでいるんですね
依存を離れることはあまり喜ばないんで
音楽を聴いて楽しいと思う人は
音楽を聴くとやめてくださいと言っちゃうとすごく怒るんです
で 何も音がない方が楽しいと言ったら
なんだこれと 音があった方が楽しいというふうに思っちゃうんですね
だから普通に我々にとってはこの離れることっていうのは楽しくないと思ったりするんですね
音を聴くことが苦っていうのが仏教の立場なんです
はい そういうことで あの
涅槃に達しなさいっていうことで終わってます
はい 八十八に行きます
タトラービ・ラティ・ミッチェイエヒトワカ